foreign
Secretary of the SNP I have been given
the results of the party leader election
2023 from my voice the ballot Services
Company
these are as follows the final number of
eligible members was 72 169.
a total of 50
494 ballot papers containing a valid
vote were received
there were three rejected postal ballot
papers the turnout was therefore 70
percent
forty eight thousand six hundred and
forty five of the ballots were cast
electronically and
1849 of the ballots were cast by post
the first preference votes are as
follows
Ash Regan
5599 this represents 11.1 percent of
first preference votes
Kate Forbes twenty thousand five hundred
and fifty nine this represents 48.7
percent of the first preference votes
336 this represents 48.2 percent of the
first preference votes
as no candidate received more than 50 of
the votes Ash Reagan as the candidate
who received the least number of Air
Force preferences was eliminated and the
second preference votes in favor of Cape
Forbes or Hamza Yusuf were given to them
the result after those votes were
redistributed was as follows
Kate Forbes 23
890 this represents 47.9 of the final
vote
Hamza Yusuf 26 000 and 32 this
represents a 52.1 final vote
I therefore declare I'm the Yusuf duly
elected as the Scottish national party
leader